sin está lista para mediar en el
conflicto entre rusia y ucrania lo ha
dicho hoy wang y el ministro de
exteriores durante la rueda de prensa
anual en la asamblea nacional popular si
no responde así a las peticiones que han
llegado en los últimos días desde eeuu
la unión europea y ucrania para que su
diplomacia desencalle el conflicto esa
neutralidad
escrupulosa que ha mantenido desde el
primer día y que le ha valido
numerosísimas críticas es ahora la mejor
y probablemente única solución a la
guerra wang ha perseverado hoy en ese
equilibrio por un lado ha defendido la
soberanía de todos los países incluida a
ucrania y por el otro ha calificado las
relaciones con su socio estratégico ruso
de sólidas como la roca china también ha
acusado a eeuu de generar el conflicto
un río no se hiela en una noche ha dicho
wang en referencia a la expansión
durante tres décadas de la otan en
europa del este también ha alertado de
que eeuu ahora está intentando crear
otra o está en el pacífico contra china
con organizaciones como el auto o el
quad